[Music]
what role is downtime had on the
severity of your depression how can one
make time for one's creative pursuits
while diminishing the vulnerability such
mental space solitude can summon this is
a very good question and i think about
this a lot
because there are times when i'm tempted
say to go to
two weeks in nature by myself
but there's definitely part of me that
is concerned that when i provide that
amount of negative space or empty space
that the thoughts and the loops that
creep in
will be
of some character that bring about
depression or anxiety mostly depression
and
one might advise me that that's true
initially and then it clears out however
i have counter examples and this is true
for my vipassana retreat that i've
spoken about at some length in the past
and spoke about at some length on dan
harris's 10 happier podcast
so if you want to hear more about that
you can
listen to the 10 happier podcast that
dan harris did with me but i had a
complete
psychological breakdown at this
vipassana retreat silent retreat
and i didn't make my life any easier by
making it much more extreme
and exaggerated in a few respects one
was coming into it six days fasted
because i really wanted to make the most
of this limited amount of time but
that is a concern so first of all i just
want to
validate that by saying you're not the
only person who thinks about this this
is something that that i certainly think
about
but your question isn't so much
one about
solitary time it's a question about down
time now it seems like you're equating
down time to making time for one's
creative pursuits
the way i think about this is a little
bit different and i would say for me
creative pursuit right now
is
dictated by
who can i interact with even if it's
just once a week even if it's once every
two weeks
how can this bring me closer to someone
i want to be closer to
and for me it's mostly pre-existing
friendships but part of my reason
the primary reason that i've thought
about doing something incredibly absurd
and effectively a parody of the space in
the nft world
is because i have all these old friends
who are scattered around the country
and we used to all be in
san francisco together and we spent a
lot of time together and had so much fun
and then
life progresses people get married
people have kids people move away and
web 3 is one of the first times that
i've seen almost all of these people
get back on the same playing field in a
way where they are interacting and
having fun
and this this by the way is not a
recommendation to invest in web 3 or
nfts i think you should assume
that pretty much everything could go to
zero and a lot of these things will go
to zero so this is not investment advice
this is psychological commentary for me
in terms of choosing projects so i am
actually choosing the playing field
first and then i'm deciding all right
which sport do i want to play on that
playing field
which position do i want to play on that
playing field but it's actually starting
with the who and not starting with the
what if that makes any sense and i found
that and have found that at least so far
to be very helpful to my mental state in
the sense that it bolsters me it feeds
me it nourishes me
as opposed to making me feel like i'm
stepping out to a cliff and peeking over
the side where i can say yeah this is a
great view but if one foot slips i could
find myself in trouble
hopefully that helps
you